now but first up she's the author of all
the single ladies unmarried women and
the rise of an independent nation and a
writer at large for New York Magazine
his recent cover stories Hillary Clinton
versus herself
Rebecca Trey stir boy you have a long
intro how you doing I'm happy to have
you all right so single women I
understand are gonna be the key voting
block in this election that's
interesting because in past elections we
heard they don't vote enough they were
the key voting bloc in 2012 as well they
were 23% of the electorate so almost a
quarter of the electorate and they voted
for Barack Obama by a kind of staggering
margin sixty-seven to 31% and by many by
many measures by many measures they are
responsible for Barack Obama getting
reelected and I have this sneaking
suspicion that the margin might be wider
when it comes to choosing between
Hillary Clinton and Donald Trump yeah
but you know who doesn't like Hillary
white women among white women Hillary
and Trump are tied what is that white
women
let's see woman woman hater well
interestingly woman hater
I though interestingly amongst white
single women single women single white
women vote Democratic as well so
marriage is the problem I always like
that married white women are your
problem married white women are your
prep they're not my problem
well let's talk about marriage you know
it's interesting the way things have
changed when I was first doing a show in
the 90s you know I had to like stick up
for the idea of being single is normal
you're not a weird person if you don't
get married and now whenever I tell
people I've never been married they're
like good for you
how'd you do it Matt I mean it's like
it's like a badge of honor there are now
more unmarried people in the United
States by about a percentage point
you're a large already nation we are a
single majority nation and it's not just
some weird trend or quirk for women
especially who historically have been
economically dependent on men have been
sexually dependent on men in eras when
they couldn't control their reproduction
through protocol or abortion have been
dependent on men if they wanted to have
socially sanctioned families right the
fact that circumstances have changed and
that now they can be earners they can
participate in public and political life
they can have liberated sex lives they
can have families without being married
what that means it displaces marriage as
the organizing institution that
organizes gendered power among other
things and it creates all kinds of new
paths for for women it remaps
right women's adulthood in a way that is
totally unprecedented and that and is
discomforting to a lot of people
I mean you said it beautifully what I
would paraphrase that is a woman doesn't
just have to marry a loser what no but
that's a revolution no it is a
revolution like before you had to marry
someone who had done now it's more like
well I'll marry somebody if somebody
great comes along and if it doesn't I'm
okay with that it raises the bar
relationships and it raises the bar on
men's behavior and and you know
yeah okay so yeah I love that word you
use you said they women used to be
hustled yeah
hustled off to the highway of marriage
yeah hustled down that Island right you
just you were pushed and at the
beginning of your adulthood because you
were dependent because you had to
establish a relationship to the kind of
American who could be an earner and who
could and who could provide you with a
socially sanctioned sex life and a
family that had to kick off your
adulthood so that for hundreds of years
the median age as long as they kept
track median age of first marriage for
women fluctuated only between 20 and 22
in 1990 it crept up over twenty three
point two twenty three point nine today
it is over twenty seven and higher than
that in many cities so even for those
who are marrying they're doing it later
and spending more years of their
adulthood outside of this institution
that historically really confined them
it's so interesting it you know
you're a little younger than me no
you're a lot younger than me okay
who isn't it this way okay so like I
graduated high school in 1974 okay so I
needed a summer job you know you hope my
summer job was I sold pots and pans
door-to-door and what they said was look
get highschool yearbooks find the women
who are not going to college and knock
on their door because they will be
needing pots and pans right right this
is I was a pretty good pots in here I
only lasted about three days it was like
what the [ __ ] am i doing I would really
I would rather get [ __ ] behind the
7-eleven this job this well this is the
difference because if if marriage was
the thing that kicked off your adult
life and your woman you know what you
were given pots and pans right and
dishes and that was your life your work
in fact was to support the public
participation of your husband the
earning of your husband by taking care
of the family doing the cooking keeping
the house that's part of how you
enforced marriage as the organizing
principle is because if you had a
population of wives sure dependent on
these earners they also then had to do
the labor that enabled the men to go out
into the world and earn and that was
pots and pans that was baby but I mean
there are still Republican politicians
who talk about that in nostalgia terms
they talk about it obsessively this is
this is Dogma for Republican politicians
MIT Romney gave a speech at a graduation
just a few years ago where he urged
everybody you know I go out there and
get married but don't just get married
marry early right this is this is
Republicans push push the idea that the
so-called success sequence right
graduating from college getting
graduating from high school college
getting married and then having a child
is the cure for poverty and everything
else that ails America but it's also
because they think if women are on their
own it's going to be government's job to
support them more that's a lot of what
it is you know we're gonna it is the
government's job to support them more as
the government has supported white men
throughout our entire history
the government enfranchise the
government in franchise its white man
and the founding protected it throughout
while disenfranchising people of color
and women the government has built
infrastructure that supported businesses
that were owned by white men who
profited the government has depressed by
not protecting wage equality by not
offering paid leave has depressed
women's ability to participate in the
workforce and compete against men for
the money in the power and has left them
as this population that needs to do the
domestic work I'm just a putt
enhancement don't yell at me I'm just
trying to sell my pots and pans all
right well thank you very much for
covering you're a great guest I hope you
join our panel sometime Rebecca